if you went back 90 years the average
age of a firm in the standard Poor's 500
would be 50 years today that number is
12 as the pace of change increases big
firms are actually in trouble managers
who are unable to deal with these
changes are failing at an increasing
pace Elcor is about helping managers
around the world to really think
systematically and manage change in
their organizations I arrived with a
serious organizational problem to solve
business provided me the opportunity to
discuss the problem and use the
knowledge of others to help me to see a
way through the problem so I've come
away with an action plan one of the
major benefits of coming to Elcor is
that not only do you get the academic
frameworks taught to you during the day
but you get to put them into practice at
night it is the only joint program
between the Graduate School of Business
at Stanford in the Harvard Business
School I got a lot of practical
takeaways that really helped me over the
following two or three years there's a
big list of things actually I have to
apply as soon as I get back just an
amazing experience and I feel so
privileged to have joined the course
this is one of the greatest places I've
been in anywhere so the weather is
beautiful the professors are top-notch
the food in this program is exceptional
and it's been a really great week this
is the most rewarding learning
experience that I've ever had it is an
extraordinary course